[Music]
thank you
[Music]
hello good morning good afternoon good
evening wherever the hell you are in the
world and welcome to Star Trek your
Sci-Fi TV and review your channel live
at all
I am here with
Iris looking on point in the right way
did you see that did you see I got I'm
getting skills
Harris and Mommy over way way over there
hello how are we both gentlemen doing
well
doing well as well you haven't got
covered that's weird
no no yeah normally one of us has
covered on these live shows don't get
too good please don't get covered
I mean I forgot my cough drops on
standby here right so please I feel a
cough coming off the Donkey Kong
so today we are going to be talking
about villains from TV and movie and
we're gonna maybe at the end pick with
your guys help who was the worst damn it
um I didn't point the wrong way Matt you
absolute bastard I didn't I pointed that
way
kit
um oh by the way guys I am going to be
live with Matt a little bit later again
I'm going to do a bit of a Stargate
video and a bit of a chat about our SGC
so join us for that later my wife has
just left the house and she's not coming
back for four days so I am taking
advantage
absolutely thank you again no that's not
the wrong way look am I doing it the
wrong way
I think it is the wrong way at least on
this screen it looks fine on my screen
I'm tickling you in the ear there look
bollocks right anyway
right so guys before we get into talking
about the villains of TV movie and with
the guys in the comments help um we're
gonna pick who's the absolute bloody
worst
we'll do what we always do let's have a
little bit of a chat about what we've
been watching this week and I'm just
going to tell you I've been really busy
so my fit in this is going to be very
short but
Paris as you're next to me and I could
tickle you in the ear
um I will see what have you been
watching this week sir
um the the usual when it comes to TV
shows so of course She-Hulk which
probably had its best episode
rings of Power House of the Dragon Rick
and Morty uh the whole nine yards but uh
film wise I saw a triangle of sadness
which is probably the funniest thing
Woody Harrelson's news like a comedy
does it no but it's great it's it's a
big political commentary but also just a
con it's just really funny it's it's
Harris Dickinson which if Harris
Dickinson's in the movie I had to go see
because it's the same name you know it's
a requirement something like that but uh
Woody Harrelson plays the captain of the
ship and it's great and one of the it's
I I can't give it away I I talk too much
about it but uh triangle sadness was
great I saw dead for a dollar and then I
also saw werewolf by night when it came
out a couple days ago
see it on my list I need to watch that
it's any good oh
it might be my third or fourth favorite
Marvel thing overall wow it's easily the
best thing that phase four has done so
far but it
honestly it it might be winter soldier
is my favorite by far and then there's
Infinity War I just love those two but
Iron Man and Guardians are kind of
probably tied for number three and it's
probably a solid number four right there
no Ragnarok
I cannot accept that for me I love
Ragnarok but I just I've got a bad taste
from Love and thunder right now talk to
me again in a couple months and I might
I'm not switch it up a little bit
fair enough I don't know I got your
feeling all right
how about you stormy bear what you been
what you've been up to well uh this uh
last uh couple days I uh binge watched
all of The Hobbit films the extended
versions I'm not taking it and I started
to fellowship with the ring last night
slash this morning
um also catching up on Westworld
handmaid's tale handmaid's tale I don't
know if you guys watch it but man I mean
it was dark to begin with
and it's just for some reason this this
season just strikes me as the darkest of
the batch I mean still good you know
Elizabeth Moss is again knocking it out
of the park directorial wise but oh my
God it's dark
um also watching uh some penny worth
House of the Dragon
rings of power
um I did see Hocus Pocus too the the new
no spoilers
yeah sure
yeah especially for the I think it was a
Florida woman that is trying to uh come
out that's come out against it warning
um conservative Christians that if you
watch this the spells that they are
casting will come through your TV
to be honest that just adds to the
flavor though right you know especially
during the Halloween party stream at the
end I mean Shenanigans will ensue uh
also Andor and catching up on She-Hulk
yeah
and or quickly I think I have a long
conversation about it well
are they the worst like Rebellion like
or terrorists ever and why is one of
them got an AK-47
I was
I totally forgot about the AKA issue
until you just brought it up it's just I
didn't again I was looking
it's definitely an ak-47. get it um and
they're just really not very good at
their jobs as well they're rubbish
and andor's the only one that knows his
ass from his elbow
um it's just it's I'm I'm watching at
the moment I'm gonna it's a bit it's
slowed down a bit and I'm like this is a
bit this is boring me again a little bit
I'm going to stick with it because
Mandalorian bored me at first and and
then I didn't come out to be like
awesome but uh three episodes in I sort
of like a bit
come on
um but they're just I just I don't get
it yeah
the uh new uh Mandalorian season three
trailer looks good
yeah she's she's so hot and we're
rocking it and going to kill somebody I
think
so yeah Andor is is coming along and
um I'm also kind of excited about
um Picard season three finally uh you've
stolen my thunder that's literally gonna
say this is the only thing I've watched
this week
okay well let's talk about Picard's the
trailer that got dunked today then
because I did a little video on it and
I've already done I did a little short
earlier just saying I was excited about
Picard series one and they let us down I
was really excited about Picard Series 2
and the first episode was awesome and
they let us down I'm really excited
about Picard series three how are they
gonna [ __ ] this up
and there's an element of it you know is
you know it's just like how are they
going to screw it up because it looks
and I I made the point in the video I
did just really quickly just talking
about off topic it looks like a Sinister
Six sort of
season it looks like all the bad guys
basically from the next generation are
coming back yeah it's like Moriarty law
whoever that wants it was which is is
going to be related somebody thinks it's
it's going to be related to Picard's son
as well from um the uh Nexus something
like that oh that I think there's going
to be all sorts of TNG references in it
um
I think bringing Moriarty back is going
to be a freaking stretch and Harris has
no freaking clue what we're talking
about but Professor Moriarty from
Sherlock Holmes was in the Next
Generation he was a hologram
Geordie accidentally went to the
computer create
um an enemy that that could defeat data
rather than defeat Sherlock Holmes so
the computer to created a Moriarty
character that knew all about everything
was clever enough to actually defeat
data it was an Android so it created a
normal craziness ensued
um and he's back in it somehow
no no out sorry well last we saw
Moriarty he was you know on an isolinear
rods
in a box disconnected from everything on
the Enterprise D which yeah destroys
well maybe he's not offloaded you know a
Jupiter station or something and he must
have done but but yeah I I'm very
excited about it I think Diana Troy is
going to get
um which will be I think early on and I
I I'm pretty excited about it so I just
know it's going to be bloody awful
by the end of pecan series one I think I
said to you this I I watched the last
episode and rather than watch that
episode again I'd rather stick my finger
in my eyeball and twirl it round you did
mention that I didn't miss that and
Picard series two by the third or fourth
episode I'd rather put my testicles in a
vice and turn the thing around then
watch it again it was that bad but not
because the show's really that bad
though to be honest the show's okay in
places but but Picard and these
characters deserve so much [ __ ]
better yeah yeah that's what makes me
sound because I'm a Trekkie because I
look I get I get trackies come on here
occasionally go you know you just you
know you're just spouting [ __ ] about
Star Trek whatever and I'm like no I
love this show so much it deserves
better and that's what makes me angry
fingers crossed
but whatever that keeps saying it's
great so
that's all my Star Trek knowledge right
there there you go but um stormy what
did you actually because I've ranted
about that because I was I was
passionate about it but what did you
actually think about the trailer what
did you think about what we've seen
uh the trailers are always exciting to
watch on for Picard
um sometimes they have nothing to do
with what the season actually turns out
to be you know
um for Q I mean I was like last season
you know they really jazzed up in the
trailers cues uh
uh presence and then it was just kind of
oh my God Q's dying he doesn't have his
powers he can't flippy Flappy and he's
just
listen
you know
and um and that's almost as much as Q's
in the series
yeah yeah yeah yeah and it was just uh
okay fine
uh
right let's talk about what we came here
to talk about the only other thing I've
watched this week was um lower decks and
it is a cringe-worthy episode to say the
least
oh I gotta go watch I haven't started on
a lower decks yet it's it's awkward
laughing once or twice
oh that's a bit but you'll understand
when you see it nice boy we won't go
into it but anyway let's talk about what
we actually came here to talk about on
this evening which is villains in sci-fi
and we've all picked um a TV and a movie
villain we're gonna pitch our case then
at the end we'll pick with the help of
you guys in the comments who is goddamn
worst
would anybody like to go first
Harris said he wanted to go first
with that too let me go first
Harris you got go on me I'm in charge
can you go first
movies or TV what are we thinking we'll
go TV first but only because those are
the notes I wrote down first Perfect all
right well I am of course having to go a
little Star Wars on this and I'm going
with Darth Maul for the villain for a
series at least and I guess that kind of
translates both to Clone Wars Star Wars
the Clone Wars and Star Wars Rebels
because he's in both of those and plays
very pivotal Parts in both but for
someone who was just a one-off movie
villain one of the greatest one-off
movie villains ever like just the most
men is literally The Phantom Menace you
know but
you don't really actually get the
character's story until you get into the
TV shows and it's not something you
would have ever expected the guy got cut
in half in the first Star Wars movie and
then becomes one of if not the most
threatening individual that the Jedi in
general has to deal with during the
Clone Wars at certain points of course
there's always General grieve there's
always Palpatine and Dooku doing their
things
he's a thorn in their side to just say
the least and uh the the guy
does all kinds of things he resurrects a
brother and takes out I think he
destroys the whole Sith hierarchy in a
certain way he even stands Toe to Toe
with Palpatine for a little bit at a
certain point so
I don't know that the guy's pretty evil
and he tries to turn a bunch of kids at
or not a bunch of kids but he tries to
turn one certain kid in Rebels into a
Sith and that may or may not have worked
in the long term we'll have to see in
the new Ahsoka series but
um
what is like the worst couple of things
that he's done that he did that well I
mean what made him a real villain
because obviously he's a weapon of the
Sith and we see that in the movie
um but he was just a soldier basically
from like so yeah but what makes him
really
he he was always the Sith assassin so he
was always just kind of
kill kill kill kill and I think he kind
of loses a lot of himself in that and
I I think some of the some of the worst
things we see him do are just
slaughtered Jedi in particular ways his
brother literally
uses his horns to stab somebody at a
certain point which is gruesome for a
children's show I mean TV y7 is great
you know uh
and he's just slicing people in half all
the time I I don't want to ruin it for
anybody so a little spoiler alert but at
the very end of season seven of Clone
Wars in the last I think two or three
episodes he has one of the I mean Star
Wars is kind of becoming known for
hallway scenes at certain points with
villains and I think Darth Maul has
easily the best hallway scene because he
doesn't have a lightsaber at all he's
literally using the force ripping panels
of ship from the ship that he's on off
and cutting people in half with it using
it to block Blaster builds throwing
panels it's just one of the best scenes
in all of Star Wars honestly and then in
Rebels he's a conniving
see you next Tuesday and he is he's just
uh-uh man he's he's bad trying to
turn the main character of rebels into
more of a dark side character uh which
you kind of gets some feelers in there
next Tuesday by the way stormy
um but well done that
I noticed stormy speed is coming through
for Halloween by the way you're doing
very well
Okay so
why if you could say in a couple of
years why did you pick Darth Maul out of
all of the villains of all of the things
you could watch why why Darth Maul
he's the guy that stuck with me I guess
Clone Wars came out the perfect time
when I was a kid I watched it on Cartoon
Network before Netflix got it before
Disney got it and I've stuck with it
ever since
yeah your impressionable age Darth
because Palpatine is evil and Diving and
smart and meticulous cunning all these
different things and Darth Maul is all
of those things to a lesser degree but
just had his vitriol just fuels him and
there are a few characters that are
fueled by vitriol and like visual alone
really and it's fun to watch let's just
be honest the reason that Harris loves
Darth mauls is because he's got a Darth
Maul ass tattoo we all know this we've
seen it it was his profile picture there
for a while so um
just straight up just like dude I don't
need to see that oh it's not small I
kind of need to see it coloring is
amazing stayed on it
it was where the lightsabers poking that
I was just like hey let's imagine just a
bit of tattoo in there
and had to try something out I guess I
don't know
okay then so Darth Maul is in the pot as
the worst ever villain I'm I'm gonna
jump in now it's like I don't think
you're gonna win this round but we'll
see we'll see
um stormy TV worst villain or your
favorite villain or well uh so um I'm
conflicted I'm conflicted as usual yeah
you know you know in terms of like
villainy
um the ones that that I felt
emotionally when I I saw the series
was the worst villain it's not really a
singular person it's like the Shadows
from Babylon 5. right yeah
and I mean they were the at the get-go
in the first episode they were the uh
they were the um the bad guys we feared
the Shadows we fought the Shadows the
whole shadow of War one called the
vorlon
and at the very end
you know when uh we tell them just to
both of them the four Lawns and the
Shadows from messing with us so many
times just both of them get the hell out
and the only real reason we liked or the
vorlons or at least put up with the
warlons or thought that the vorlons were
on our side is because they had a lot to
do with um nimbari culture several years
back
and so it's just but the Shadows always
seemed I mean there was never
I mean there was cost an actual
character for the vorlons right
I mean I unless the there was lots of
people that acted in service to the
Shadows but we never really saw a shadow
or knew the name of a shadow cat we saw
them the the actual personification the
actual physical form of the Shadows
but they just kind of creeped me out and
they they were I mean they would stop at
nothing to destroy
they bited their time and you never knew
they were coming until they were there
and they're the chaotic nature of the
Shadows I think made them especially
fearful
and they had the best Finland spaceships
and oh my God yeah it's they had the um
the best films for spaceships and when
they had the little uh the Starfighter
one of the Shadows that captured what
you know and just was just hauling it
inside and you could kind of see it and
say oh
creepy yeah that was creepy with the new
Babylon 5 series I asked this when I did
a video about it a little while ago I I
said you know they've got to bring back
the core of what Babylon 5 is to bring
if this new series gets made
um the most recent rumor I heard was
it's not
um but anyway and apparently the Warner
Brothers were arguing about whether they
wanted it to put it on HBO Max or the CW
The CW are refusing to let it go into
HBO Max so Warner Brothers is sort of
like well we're just gonna like we won't
let you make it
I mean how childish is that but anyway
um so we'll see what happens next I
think we'll know in the next two weeks
um but
I said you've got to have like what the
core of Babylon five is you've got a
Babylon five obviously I think you've
got to have the membari war
do you have to have the Shadows
oh no I mean there are so many races
in that series that you could I mean you
could
you could have them in Barry War you
know you could have you know life and
time of zathras on the Prairie you know
there's all sorts of
um a material there you can work from
you don't have to have a shot
yeah I want to see the Shadows though
five was the Shadows I wanna that's the
shadow series three a Babylon five was
this some of the best sci-fi we've ever
seen you know it's like the Deep Space
Nine was desperately trying to copy it
as far as I was concerned it seemed to
be
um
you will die
I love Bruce boxing from um scarecrow
and this is crane this is crane thank
you I loved him back then and he did a
movie with an elephant in that I really
like to stop so he's just one of those
like black just when he's in battle
files I was like yeah it's all done for
me happy days
I love Babylon because it was called the
poor man Star Trek but it's better you
must
Five Seasons they did okay it's on the
nose I like it
watch it if ever you get a chance
um
the first season's a bit boring second
season is good third season is awesome
fourth and the fifth the wave a little
bit but
um yeah that's I I'd agree with David
they've kind of got to have the Shadows
because they're the best bit
but it could go in a different direction
as I said the membari wars has got to be
in there because it's why we built
Babylon five right unless it goes a
completely different direction
but he's got to do something different
with it though isn't he he's got to do
he can't just remake Babylon five
he's got to do something different so or
we'll we'll know where it's going
right so let's see what he does we'll
find out anyway he's obviously got an ID
um my choice now I know this is largely
a Stargate Channel
all last Target videos do the best
videos and a lot of the subscribers
subscribe because of the script I talk
about Stargate so I went with a new this
because I want to be popular and I don't
want people to like me
so um so now I genuinely think he's I've
actually did the video ages and ages and
ages ago saying I think he's the best
villain and how many villains actually
right Thanos killed half of the Galaxy
for a bit
Anubis came that close and again Harris
hasn't seen this suit so there's gonna
be a lot of spoilers in the next five
times
yeah oh he's going to be excited I'm
going to tell you all the crappy things
he did over the time you're going to be
so excited but he came that close to
destroying all life in the Milky Way and
he came on that close
so we'll go through a couple of this he
was played by Five actors in Stargate in
different forms but um George oh
was by far the best that was the guy in
there um in the imaginary Diner
bit then I've got his actual name in the
episode now because Samuel
anyway
um but he was awesome in that
um he was so evil
that the gold walls didn't banished him
basically that's because he was so evil
even he was too evil even for the gold
and they kicked him out ra banished him
um he then tricked
um Omar desala um at Keb into basically
ascending him and they didn't realize
just how evil he was until too late so
he like partially ascended and that's
like they tried to bounce him back but
it didn't really work he's kind of in
both planes for a little while
um the others either had to step in
basically everybody has stepped in Noah
oh man stop stop sending just anybody
you meet in the street you idiot
um
he wiped out the toll and have you seen
the towel we've seen the toll and yet
where you are haven't we Harris here
right he pretty much wipes them out
um there's a few refugees left and
that's about it
um okay he goes back to the system Lords
even though he's been banished once he's
gained a bit of power and he promises if
he's allowed to become a system Lord
again he'll Wipe Out the Towering he'll
wipe us out and he lobbed an asteroid at
us
um and that could have heavy asteroid so
we that nearly wiped out
um he captured he got to a technological
point that he was able to take on the
Asgard one-on-one he was able to capture
um Thor and put this spiky ball in his
head to exact information from him and
he'll kill Thor he's only went three
O'Neil class Starships turned up and he
went away and he ran away
um
he then created a super weapon went to
aberdos destroyed that
um so he wiped out what I said he
captured Jonas Queen who you don't know
yet killed him
now all right well he dies
doesn't kill him actually but he dies
because no no he doesn't die doesn't I
forgot he doesn't die but he has to go
home because
um uh owners call him thunderstorm
Anubis goes and he [ __ ] the planet up
and you know
um all all good fun
he is so evil the system Lords actually
gang together led by bar and fight
against him that's how much I would see
you next Tuesday this guy is
um and then it creates the call Warriors
which are just freaking awesome
um even though they look like
sperm or something when they check the
helmets off and they look a bit weird
um he's in a very cool episode where he
goes on the International Space Station
and he's his Spirit jumps into a Russian
cosmet oh it's just awesome and then he
goes to dakara where there is the secret
weapon that the Ancients built actually
to
um respawn life in the Milky Way after
the um uh I think it was the ore I tried
to wipe us out with a plague
um five million years ago and they used
that to respawn I think they switched it
to wipe all life out and if it wasn't
for
um Omar they've started all this mess in
the first place basically stepping in
they she basically it lets him Ascend
all the way so his Spirit leave our
plane so he can't finish and then locks
him into Immortal Battle For Eternity
because it's the only way to defeat him
so he's not really gone he's just in an
immortal arm wrestle with another with
another ascended Bean
so my argument for Anubis being the
worst villain in history is because none
of your villains come as close to wiping
out all life
is heated
that close like I said he's so evil even
the gold thought he was a bad man
that's pretty freaking evil well he does
have the resume for it doesn't he yeah
he's got a pretty happy resume there hmm
Andy wore a dark black cloak
um like the emperor but when he lived
when he dropped the coke there was just
like a wobbly thingy there it was even
more time
oh yeah I mean
I mean
some of these guys that George has gone
into this and said in George you know
flexman said the human replicators the
worst I knew this was worse for me but
he was just evil for the sake of being
evil as well he was in I mean he was he
was a very very Angry Young Man
um so that that's my vote for the worst
villain
in TV
so we'll move on to movies and we'll
come back to it in the end and we'll
decide before we do I was I had another
choice in case you gave me [ __ ] about
these Shadows not being a singular
person it's still from uh it's still
from Babylon 5 and I think that's her
Alfred bester the head of the cycor was
the worst guy ever he was a scumbag he
was I mean he was manipulative
evil self-serving
uh controlling domineering
dictatorship Tendencies just he was it's
really evil
I'll tell you what let's go slightly off
tangent for a second because that's a
really good point you made that as I
said people that weren't if can you
think of anybody in TV shows because
I've won another one jumped from
Stargate jumped into demand it was just
a little conniving selfish twerk and I
can't remember his name
and but he was the guy that in the first
of the move he's got a replicator in the
back of his head
um and they and the replicator took him
over
um
I have to Google him but um he was such
a little but he wasn't really like evil
like in this this level of villain but
he was when the replicator did take him
over and think I was happy about it
um because he was just such a twerp
bester was similar to me then he was
just like yeah he was he was selfish he
wasn't really like a villain he wouldn't
do anything to be evil he was just
selfish and
and just just to get yeah he was played
by Walter Koenig um and he did such a
good job honestly you just you wanted to
reach into the TV and just go oh
yeah
there's a really good I'm sorry Harris
go ahead
good I was just saying I love good small
villains Game of Thrones and House of
the Dragon are like I think they do the
best in that just having like smaller
characters that just you despise because
there's a giant that you despise more
but just some really short he was the
doctor or the scientist or whatever that
made the mountain
foreign
there's a series of novels by J Gregory
keys I think it's available on Kindle
called the scicor trilogy it's really
good I mean if if you're wanting you
some extra Babylon 5 but that try those
uh books they were really really good
and
um one thing one of the last thing I was
wanting to uh bring up and I think I've
already forgot it damn it
oh uh speaking of uh Game of Thrones are
the um the rumors for the Jon Snow
series true
yeah that there are plans for Jon Snow
series
yeah and then it'll be on the The Watch
apparently
um
there are about four Game of Thrones
projects in development apparently
um there's another one there's another
like prequeline one there's uh Jon Snow
um a Starks series I believe
um yeah and one that was going to be
based um
at the in the capital city again but
King's Landing they're you know King's
Landing this but there's yeah they're
supposed to be four or even five Series
in early development at the moment
I think they sort of wait and I've seen
how how should the dragon would do and
they must be pretty impressed by itself
I mean
I'm impressed I mean House of the Dragon
is really good I love it it's fantastic
the the other people for House of the
Dragon like is the coralish the sea
snake right
okay
we'll see what happens with it but um
I imagine they'll probably try to we'll
we'll there'll be something announced
shortly now because I reckon they'll do
the second season of House of the Dragon
then they'll do something else then
it'll be the third season of House
delivering I think House of dragons got
four or five seasons planned I think I
think it's five how old is five I've
heard five but you know so and then
they'll they'll start staggering them
like they do don't they but I mean
they can do so many different things
with it
yeah I've got a question for you guys
actually just before we move on to the
movies one as well
sci-fi was going through a real like
Renaissance for the last few years
everything you know like all the best TV
shows on things sci-fi um the last few
years it's fantasy overtook it
I don't know it seems to be fantasy now
hmm well I mean I think it does you know
back and forth between fantasy and
sci-fi fantasy and sci-fi not just in
terms of the Sci-Fi channel
uh but I think in general takes because
you know you'll see you know uh a
predominance of uh sci-fi titles on the
New York Times bestseller list and all
the you know a few years later there'll
be fantasy titles it's like you know
elves lightsabers elves like okay we get
we get our full valves oh my God we
gotta have some lightsabers then we just
go back and forth
yeah it seems to be I think fantasies
overtook it at the moment but it could
be for HBO though after Game of Thrones
what was their only other big big big
series that kept the workflow for a
couple years Westworld yeah even though
it's kind of
dive down a little bit after season
three uh I like season two but are you
in season four yet stormy is that what
you keep talking about yeah yeah yeah oh
yeah
is supposed to be picking him back up
again they're really happy with it and
it's the popularity ticked up again a
little bit I heard the opposite uh
there's the people saying it was really
good okay I like them I mean season four
I'm I'm really into I really need to
catch up with it only what's the first
tears
I didn't have the channel for a while
and I sort of forgot about it now I've
got the channel again like I really need
to pick that up but um
it's just amazing but second I think is
really well done too but almost like
looking for the things I'm looking
forward to though I think for the next
12 months I don't think not any of them
are sci-fi particularly
um or what's officially been announced
it's like Witcher season three and
things like that I'm really looking
forward to
so let's see but okay movies movie
villains let's do movie villains so
Harris again please go first so start us
off well I'm I'm gonna start us off with
the classic then all all Terminator 1000
T1000 from T2 Robert Patrick's police
skin changing shape-shifting metal
shifting whatever it may be he's kind of
Magneto all rolled up into one he's he's
just the the prime villain that so many
villains have been archetyped off of
since then
um I don't know that guy is just evil to
the core he's literally programmed and
designed to be evil to be more evil than
the original T800 had been because he
comes back being friendly yet you know
so
I can't plug it can't plug a USB port
into a liquid metal can you to reprogram
it
no but no I I think he is
Pure Evil and incarnate literally he's
used as his whole purpose is to do and
to stop possibly the only good thing the
only possibly good thing to happen uh
from happening so I don't know that that
is evil incarnate in my eyes I love
anything as well that is and the special
effects obviously for a lot of the t2
we've never seen before you know we'd
never saw a lot of that liquid metal and
a lot of the CGI that was used but then
as well so much of it was just tinfoil
stuck onto a uniform
um and you know them playing with
magnesium and stuff and things you know
so I love that I I there's a TV series
on Netflix at the moment about um like
movies that made us I suggest you go and
watch them there's watch the Home Alone
one how many it's a really nice insight
into like how movies are really made
um and how Home Alone almost didn't get
made and then it was literally people
running around there they kind of made
it and sort of like almost like for the
bosses
um
I just I just I love I love so yeah
definitely go and watch that series it's
a brilliant Insight in town movies are
really made and how it's far less
professional than you think it should be
uh yeah someone a lot of the rumors I
keep hearing now that I'm sort of like
more of it I'm like that can't be true
for my guy I speak to you I'm like it is
these decisions cannot be made this way
this is like they are so it's like um
it's a hundred million dollars worth of
investment they cannot just do it on a
whims made on napkins and off-headed
jokes it's great it's amazing but then
but yeah so go watch that series it's
fantastic and but they did Terminator
and they did that they did talk a lot
about the the special effects and things
and it's it was
um it's one of those movies that's just
every so often every few years a movie
comes out isn't it there's like the
Matrix Avatar T2 Predator die hard every
few films these films come out and
they're just like that is an instant
classic
how many of them did James Cameron at
least have a hand in yeah half our room
well aliens
yeah
amazing movie I blew my mind
yeah yeah Matt did bring up a good point
though
I'm not I'm not I can't tread back at
this point I'm I'm full in on T1000
being evil but he does make a good point
where he's he's programmed to be evil so
it's is he actually evil can he be evil
if everything else is programmed to be
evil to him I feel like yes because of
the the people or the programs that
programmed him are no different at that
point he's essentially an AI making his
own decisions so
he is is he really evil or is he just
efficient
you know I mean you know he's carrying
out his program so is he really evil or
is he just efficient
he's cruel at crimes cruel yeah
even though he is a program I think just
from what we see it seems like the
program itself does enjoy the evil doing
that he's doing it's not like
it's not Arnie just walking forward you
know he Arnie develops a little bit of a
soul in T2 and I think Robert Patrick's
kind of T-1000 does too and it's just
kind of an antithesis to uh the t800s
yeah because how can you be around
people for a little bit not get a soul
whether it be good or bad
yeah and I mean obviously they we can
get into a long conversation about what
is evil
um because actually Skynet was just
trying to defend itself so you could
argue it's not really evil we tried to
pull the plug and it was defending
itself
um so but
if you are cruel I would argue that's an
evil action but evil because that's a
that's a word we invent to describe
these sorts of things isn't it it's not
it's not really a thing it's a concept
and he does commit cruel Acts so
it means to do together but yeah
um
okay well we'll throw him in the pot
mate we'll throw him in the pot so when
the party goes
yours for movies who's your movie
villain
all right so if you guys been watching
the last I don't know 50 million live
streams with us three you will
definitely know I'm a Tolkien fan so
therefore it has to be Sauron
period I win all the prizes it's Sauron
you're welcome
hey siren again I forget
I mean because you know it's uh for
thousands of years as long as you know
the elves have been around he's been
actively trying to destroy every single
living thing in Middle Earth the elves
the hobbits he even if he has to move
through his beloved orecai he just
doesn't care
he wants his jewelry back guys he just
won't yeah you know he he got that
promise ring and he just doesn't want to
give one up
are you doing stuff right I'm sorry I
got my ring on I think it's not doesn't
give me any power it actually attention
an hour away from me but um
I was like I got married I haven't made
a decision since I just asked permission
a lot
um but
the um Sauron what was his motivation
being a tokenist I'm not as big a
talker's thing is he is he just evil for
the sake of being evil or was there
actually
but he he I mean he he was evil I mean
you know he he's uh when he made the One
Ring he pour all of his hate all of his
malice I mean he did not put love and
puppies into the ring I mean he
he purposely used malice hate and fear
as a weapon again
huh he's got his own type of puppies
that he likes oh my God
okay point one he has Ward puppies and
they're not still not kids
it definitely looks like a cat person to
me as a side note you know I got a work
second shift building spaceships out
here in the California desert I was
coming home the other night and I heard
a bunch of coyote puppies at 3am playing
off into in the desert and then the mom
was having none of it
and it went on for like 20 minutes it
was just lovely but they were not orgs
they were coyote puppies
bad guy he's not even welcome at the
green dragon I mean that's how bad it is
yeah he's not well liked no
but I'm in the Orcs love him but other
than that but isn't it Middle Earth in
in a different person's vision
it's not so easy
he's not so evil huh he's trying to
reshape Middle Earth in a different
person's vision
even morgoth thought he was a bad guy
well that's true okay
I mean
wargoth was kind of uh Sarah and was
kind of The Apprentice to morgoth way
way way back in the day oh actually I
remember that from The Ring of Power I
do remember him being mentioned
the only thing you have to do is read
really 40 30 really thick books and
you'll catch up okay okay
get right on it right
okay we're throwing in the pot hey he's
got a lovely Crown anybody with a crown
I'm thinking yeah spiky Joby
um and yeah and he was a big bugger so
okay yeah
for me this is going to throw in another
debate on what is evil but it kind of
did it on purpose I've picked this
because there's going to be a new TV
series next June based on this this
villain or this this evil thing
um the original
um working title for the movie was star
Beast which is I thought I thought an
interesting
and anybody in the comments know what
I'm talking about star Beast he was I'm
going to keep talking about it and then
see if anybody comes up in the comments
is star Beast the thing in star-lord's
pants
yeah yeah it is okay oh yeah how'd you
know yeah
this is the one-eyed star Beast
um yeah it could be it could be
um it was originally created by H.R
Geiger who was so sick that um one of
one director went to speak to him this
guy doing the Jew and he came away with
it going we can't use his stuff the
guy's nuts
is is the alien from the alien franchise
the xenomorph xx121 the intern vicious
more practice
but I want to go this villain because
aliens was one of my favorite films on
this kid I've never that bothered about
aliens I found it a little boring when I
was little you know what I mean because
I was allowed to watch far too many 18
movies when I was a kid
um but it never it never I thought it
was a bit a bit slow isn't it when
you're a kid I'll watch it back now and
I'm like [ __ ] this is this is that
Thriller this is you know so good but um
but aliens just like they guys just turn
up memories just turn up machine guns
just blow everything to [ __ ] for two
hours I mean it's freaking amazing I
love that movie and Bill Paxton in it
um the one fact I heard was um
apparently
the word [ __ ] is said about 55 times or
something like that in the alien movie
um 40 something of them are Bill
Paxton's character
no bill yeah I miss him he was a greater
yeah he was brilliant um what's the
movie
um two guns with um Mark Wahlberg and
Denzel Washington and he plays the
villain in that to be honest character
that's such a fun movie I want to see
that with my dad and we both had such a
good time oh it's just it's I it's the
best like body
like movie that we've seen in a while
they don't really make those sorts of
films anymore but it's just classic it's
absolutely brilliant deserved loads of
yeah I wish they made more but we are
getting a buddy film out of
Deadpool and Wolverine
yeah we are yeah yeah okay
yeah I'm not I'm not sure about that but
we'll see what happens when I first saw
that I thought it was a meme
that's crazy you know butt toy meme I
just didn't know what was wrong but
I found a few little interesting facts
about the xenomorph before we um go on
to how evil he was though for one James
Cameron came on to do aliens
um but the a lot of the crew was so like
loyal to Ridley Scott they refused to
work and there was open fights so James
Cameron had to bring a lot of his own
crew on
um a lot of the crew that worked under
Ridley Scott refused to talk to James
Cameron's wife because they said she was
only a producer because she was Jim
Cameron's wife so they refused to
acknowledge her and film him
um
how they built the alien the original
alien was they used Rolls-Royce parts
actual rib bones
um a load of snake vertebrae that they
got from somewhere and then all molded
with plasticine and that's how they
built the damn thing
and the guy that appeared in it Ridley
Scott said we've got to do this with we
can't do with animatronics and things
we're gonna have to do the person needs
to be in the suit for the original
um so they found a guy called Balaji
badejo it was a six foot tense skinniest
hell mime artist
um and they chucked him in the suit and
that's why they did it cost him in the
suit it's the minds they're always the
creepiest I'm just saying yeah limes are
creepy I think actually we've we've just
gone back to immediately now who were
the biggest villains
[ __ ]
I don't know if you guys remember or not
but back in the 70s there used to be
this mime troop called Mom and chance
Tonight Show with uh Johnny Carson
it was a whole mind troupe and they I
mean they were supposed to be
entertaining and so forth but their acts
was a little bit on the creepy side
dude I was born in 1948 and I'm British
Johnny Carson is very is very limited in
my thing
um I do like Matt's comment there Matt's
that reminds you of one weakness
imagining and ropes that they can't get
up
um
Zach Tati
is that anyone about I don't know why
George is put it up must be a mime it
must be a moment
um
apparently there's another one as well
uh so Cameron gave the alien crew snake
showing of aliens but very few of them
showed up
um so another thing was apparently when
Sigourney Weaver first saw the first cut
of aliens she said publicly that he
wouldn't do any more he hated it
apparently
um which is mental because it's just a
good film
um there's loads of different variations
of the aliens that we've seen there's
the dragon the predalian the Deacon the
neomorph of cyndallings
but we have the argument now is predator
actually evil we could have women
bad noise coming through
stopped or are they just an animal
you know is it any worse than a lion
a load of lions with acid blood fair
enough but are they just an animal
continuing with that argument though
like most Predators lions tigers bears
oh my included you know they do not
typically
continue to hunt after they've hunted
one
kill down when they get a kill they eat
they Feast they rest disciple
Xenomorphs kill to kill
they they think who knows they probably
eat after the fact but they do kill to
kill so that does kind of take any kind
of or a little I guess
what do they eat
I'm after watching Prometheus though I'm
wondering if the real villains are the
engineers
because that they're not nice and don't
get me wrong I understood for very
little of that movie
um I spent most of it just looking at
them at trees
um that's got a name Charlize Theron
Charlize Theron
um as I always do I watched them uh Snow
White in the Huntsman last night
just because I thought I remember
Charlize the Thrones in it
um
but um but uh yeah I didn't really
understand that movie greatly but I mean
it seemed like the engineers were the
bad guys and they'd created
the aliens is a weapon
so in that case
but
they created us as well yeah they create
us as well yeah there's a big circle of
life I don't know but I mean there's a
scary monster in a movie there's not
many that are more terrifying than the
aliens is it
it was the movie monster that started a
lot of movie Monsters off not really I
guess we had the 1940s horror stuff from
Universal but that was like the first
New Age monster after all that I feel
like and a lot of those monsters are
already you know present in classic
literature for some time you know
Wolfman Frankenstein you know
hmm
so yeah up to me they're the ones that
scared that they scared the bejesus out
of me
um when I was a kid
um I remember in Aliens a bit where uh
the robots go through the tunnel and you
know they're coming through oh they're
scared of Jesus at me
um and they're just the perfect killing
machine as well because if you kill them
if they're close enough they kill you
anyway
they're just they're just and obviously
there's that whole thing about being
captured and like
spat on and you know I assuming spit
um so you know like put the Cocoon thing
and then the thing jumps on you and
impregnates you and then then you're
just waiting to die I don't know man
they're just they're just [ __ ]
terrifying from beginning to end
um
but but yeah it's uh to me they're the
most terrifying so right guys we have to
make a decision
hidden um out of the three and guys get
in the comments and if you if you want
to throw in a vote here out of the three
of the TV villains or any other that you
can think of that you want to throw in
last second I mean if you want to throw
Daleks in now you you you're welcome to
even though they're
they're kind of murderous yeah they they
like a bit of killing
um
but we have to think what is the worst
and especially I think about what's the
criteria for saying the worst what is
this the most villainous and what was
actually the most dangerous because I
think that's maybe a little bit
different because I understand you can't
beat Anubis for Dangerous he nearly
wiped out everything
I win
um
what was he the most villainous is he
the one that scared you the most because
I don't I never actually found him
particularly scary
I have thought of another one that's
going to jump to mind that actually was
to genuinely terrifying but what do you
guys think it was like scary
um
well I think you know going back to
the Ambassador he was definitely the
biggest villain but he wasn't the
scariest you know I think the shadows in
terms of scariness
um
he just really hated bester but you
really were scared of the Shadows
yeah yeah I think they were they were
taxi generally terrified
if we go out of sci-fi and just one
second though
um terrifying villains the first Friday
the 13th genuine Academy
I mean like I don't really like horror
movies because I think horror is if it
scares you I'm scared I don't like being
scared I like being feeling brave
um
or um or if they're not scary then
what's the [ __ ] point
you know what I mean it's like um so but
but Friday the 13th genuinely scared me
to the point where I had nightmares and
um Tim Curry's take on it was genuinely
terrifying that is terrifying yeah I
know neither of those aside from we're
talking sci-fi but you're talking scary
well what
what sci-fi horror one of one of the
things which I need I was gonna watch
today but I have that stunt stuff going
on so I don't know if I I will get the
chance or not
um so I'll probably watch tomorrow
nonetheless but they have a new version
of it but I Clive Barker's original
Hellraiser scared the living [ __ ] out of
me when I was young I've never actually
seen it
I love it I've never seen it it's got
sci-fi it's got kind of a little bit of
Fantastical elements to itself and stuff
demon stuff in it it's got I mean it's
it's everything but done well and
it's just it's spooky every year
that I know is of seeing the TV show and
think it's better than the original film
I'm so excited I am getting a really
good reviews isn't it things that people
have seen sneak peeks are saying this is
genuinely terrifying they're saying this
is like um
um oh I forgot the name of the show
oh crap
um
it's on American actually it's American
this is American Horror and they do
different ones each oh American Horror
Story yeah yeah yeah American Horror
Story they did one a few years ago that
genuine piece that was terrifying about
witches or something and I'd advice I
had it's not for me I didn't watch it
but um they're saying it's better than
that they're saying that they're
actually very similar Style
um but it's you know I've heard a few
people say it's it's properly brilliant
so we'll see how it goes but
it's not for me you just used to Matt
said he got chased by Pinhead in an
interactive war room and almost cried
active horror room things like escape
room things but it was interactive but I
wasn't listening when we went in
I have a I have a habit of this I phase
out and I look at the wall and things
and I go so I wasn't really listening so
I didn't know there were people in there
so this guy jumped out at me wearing
like a horror thing I punched him in the
face really hard I got in so much
trouble a guy came in and dragged me out
and I'm just like but it just just
surprised me
[Laughter]
so I got into trouble
um you got told he was like I wasn't
listening
one movie that really terrified me I
mean for years really affected my mental
health for years for some reason my
grandparents let me watch uh Wizard of
Oz when I was three years old
and those damn flying monkeys lived in
my closet in my room and I just knew it
little they were in there crawling
around and for years I had to sleep with
the light on because of the stupid ass
flying monkeys
I don't know how old I was when I
watched Friday the 13th but my parents
probably should have had Social Services
involved
way too young and that was that's the
movie I have nightmares about it's when
they're in the thing and he comes and
he's scraping his nails across like the
tank of the metal I genuinely remember
and uh and when uh Johnny Depp gets
killed as well that's that is that I
genuinely even have nightmares about
that now I wake up every so often and go
oh [ __ ] that was it that generally
affected me
attention
the original yeah but um I must have
watched it when I was about eight or
something I was I was young enough that
I don't know how old I was I'm not sure
so I must have been like I wasn't in
secondary school I'd I'd remember if I
what age I was so I must have been like
eight or nine or something my parents
were bad parents
we sat they sat down and watched think
about things that horrified me
um the cartoon of um
uh what's the the rabbits
um uh uh oh I know what you're talking
about where there's Watership Down holy
[ __ ] down so my parents aren't Christmas
worship Amazon
so they put us down and we were only
little and they put us down in front of
the things watch it down and then they
wondered why my little brother was
crying and I was like and I went
upstairs or something and they came and
well what's wrong
but they just thought it was a rabbit
cartoon that they were expecting like
looking oh my gosh
[Music]
that rabbit was mean to that rabbit it
was just like Jesus Christ but yeah they
they didn't screen
or do any you know check after all they
just sits down from oh God anyway
um so what are we picking them for the
most terrifying sci-fi bad guy then
what do we think yeah TV what did we
picking it's a newbie whatever you said
Harris it was so long ago now and um
Darth Maul
Shadows Shadows the Shadows
obviously I think it was Anubis but
Shadows were cool well I I think is it's
it's a toss-up between the um
the shadows and Anubis
um my man Darth Maul he what about what
about the order 66
Millions upon Millions
well we've so did a lot of other
Stormtroopers we just you know
the Shadows actually did it though
didn't they they were they were they did
a lot of killing there was there was and
if you think about it the Shadows were
doing it for millions of years as well
they kept slaughtering some crime and
then going to sleep then coming back so
that that part is probably the highest
point of view
yeah
I'm going with Dave on this one Shadows
should we go I'm happy with that um I
know I know Harris is still there going
oh
strong millions of years that sounds
like a Galactus Herald kind of thing
no go watch it and then in a couple of
months Time come back yeah I gotta go
watch Babylon I gotta I gotta binge that
now I'll put it on the list because I
gotta get through Stargate and then I I
really do want to watch Farscape
and chose Stargate over it so
B5 and Farscape but like yeah they're a
bit they're they're similar style and
stuff and yeah that fast case is
brilliant as well so right cool we
picked it shadows and four movies we've
obviously got aliens the xenomorph which
I suggested we got Sauron on the end
that way and we've got whatever Harris
said which I've now forgotten what you
said that on that one as well God we
will forget
right
and we're talking about cool the T-1000
wins he was a cool villain the special
effects were cool he made that movie and
it's one of the biggest movies in
history
and look how many things how many you
know um
off of that theme of you know a uh
sorry
he thinks he's gonna win
so no I just looked down in the the chat
and I saw Hal 900.
I mean
again not really evil because do you
have to be biological to be evil well I
mean you know uh HAL 9000 he was you
know he was set up you know he was
forced to lie you know and so is how is
the HAL 9000 the evil one or
the uh the city that forced him to lie
which is yeah yeah
interesting well it wasn't Hayward Floyd
because Hayward Floyd knew nothing about
what was going on
you know but you know they had there was
someone who had a secret agenda and Al
got tangled up with it and had to lie
and then kill a couple people yeah
I haven't watched Blake seven in a very
long time but John does make a good
point she was a [ __ ]
um okay so we're talking about that then
you know
Kai win
kaiwan yeah oh God there's so many good
feelings face Karen right
another another suggestion we haven't
suggested and it was iconic
they were the best villain in Star Trek
yes
well no because Picard ruined them and
made them all a bunch of Nancy boys
so I like saying Nancy boy I don't think
I might say that am I
um but made them all a bit late
me
um ruin the Borg do you know how good a
TV show or how bad a TV show has to be
to ruin the Borg
you know it's simple they turn up it's
like making the Daleks if the Daleks
come down and went we're gonna save the
environment for you it's that bad you're
like oh we've got a you know we're gonna
clean up all the oil off these dead
pigeons Jayden we trigger you again I'm
so sorry yeah Star Trek just make me
angry
I love it so but it makes me angry
um but yeah no the Borg getting out of
[ __ ] but anyway the pork were a
brilliant villain
and everything and the Dominion were
never that scary to me and the thing but
the ball grew awesome and in in Voyager
they're some of the best voyager
episodes
just just brilliant
um
okay so so since we're talking about
that
I I I I I either I saw a rumor or a fan
film something about
um a new spin-off called the defiant
it might have been a fan fiction maybe
because there are loads of them for Star
Trek in there yeah I mean it was like
the wharf steals the defiant it goes on
and goes off and does something it was
like um somebody there was no there was
rumors years ago Wharf has been trying
to do a spin-off Star Trek series for
years
um and the one of the ones he pitched
was
um something based around the defiant
um but but actual Michael Dawn has been
trying to get a wolf series made for
years
um so I think it was that it's possibly
that
um but as far as I know it didn't get
made or nothing got done with it and
there aren't any rumors for that now at
the moment yesterday comicbook.com
announced Star Trek Defiance series
announced well let's have a look
yeah
um
it was it was like Star Trek they had
loads of announcements yesterday
so let's have a look
New York Comic Con or something probably
yeah I think so yeah uh yeah
comic-con.com head topic Star Trek to
fight series announced was that so it's
going to be with Warfare
wow he's been trying to make for ages
yeah I'm trying to find the new flagship
series Star Trek Masters blah blah blah
the fact is part of the same massive
story that we'll craft them together
expect crossovers
wow okay I how did I miss that
well I just saw it I I it came across my
phone like 2 A.M my time this morning
while I was winding up The Hobbit series
and I just you said something one of you
guys said something and it triggered
like oh oh oh defiant I was wanting to
talk about this you're triggered again
five I got that's see now they've kept
that really quiet as well because we
know about a few other things they've
kept that really quiet
it's quiet
what's Discovery coming back yay
but it's got like Royal Aaron
my Torres
really yeah
Alana Torres
okay
I don't want to see her in anything okay
I didn't want to see her in Voyager
boring [ __ ] excuse me about more
favorite characters I liked her I was
never bothered but anyway okay we'll see
what they do with that that's
interesting I've missed that oh after I
need to get on truck yards and stuff see
that's the thing I I subscribe to loads
of Trek YouTube channels and none of
them have done a video on it
well here you go you can you can break
the news to YouTube World Jay with your
side track Channel
and here we are talking about Sarah damn
yeah where have you been
I know
and they talked about things even track
culture that hasn't done a video on it
so
um yeah David says it feels it was going
to be a comic maybe it's a comic
what are they doing that would make
sense because it was on Comic Con
it's in a comic book website I think
it's gonna be a comic book note
um
it doesn't actually say it's a comic but
that would make more sense
easier to do
yeah 100 in a lot easier to do because
it's going to be the actual design we
know it would actually be set around
that time period wouldn't it so I think
that that makes more sense if it's going
to be a comic or you could do a click
bait thing and just say it's a TV show
I
public podcast do that let's go back
later I've started talking to the guys
on podcast quite a lot so I shouldn't be
mean about them really but they do
occasionally do videos that are
blatantly not true
unfortunately
um
but hey
and they spend a lot of the video
so much of the videos that they do
talking about whoever's sponsoring them
and I was like oh every podcast video if
you're ever watching it just flick
forwards to like six minutes that's when
they actually tell you something but I
sound so bitter because I've got 100 000
subscribers and I haven't
what are we saying right so movie
villain we have to pick one yeah
um oh yeah
very cool yes power on
no
um aliens and all of the other things
that we've mentioned since
oh it's hard ain't it yeah
because HAL 9000 is kind of the
predecessor to Skynet
I I I I might go with Hal over T1000 but
at the end of the day I'm kind of
feeling the aliens
Hal is kind of iconic
yes it's really evil once again yeah and
if you ain't seen the movie you still
know that Big rednecking Blob
um
we might have to just say that we don't
know because they're just too brilliant
they are they are good you know it was
uh
I think in terms of uh sci-fi uh the the
xenomorph I mean I saw the movie
originally in in theaters
and it was in in 1979 I think it was it
was so terrifying
um certain uh theaters banned the film I
don't know if you knew that eight the
original alien was a banned movie
because it was so terrifying
and uh of course I found the theater
that was showing it and during the
frightening scenes you can't see it as
much or hear it as much on television
but there was this heartbeat
in the in the audience and it's very
discernible and it got a little bit
faster a little bit faster as the
tension built up you don't you really
can't hear it that much on the stream or
anything like that but it was it really
drove it home and when that little
[ __ ] jumped out of his chest I mean it
was just it was terrifying you know in
H.R Giger you know which designed all of
this he was particularly in trouble
during that period of time he did a
cover for uh the cover art for a record
album by the Dead Kennedys oh yeah and
the debt record that album got banned
because of Geiger's art and the FBI
actually interviewed uh the Dead
Kennedys I can't remember the lead's
name
of the Dead Kennedys and uh he wanted to
know where this Giger fellow was and
they you know starkly replied well he's
in Switzerland you can't get to him the
guy that was the producer that met him
came away and said he thought he was a
psychopath yeah he oh
Geiger you know lived with his mother
for a very long time you know he was his
house for one I really think you know
H.R Ginger was a little bit on the
he said one second oh okay so I really
think uh Giger was a little bit on the
autistic side I really do think so
possibly I mean a lot of creatives I
mean three out of the top five most
wealthy people in the planet right now
are on the autism spectrum you know so
yeah some of the most Brilliant Minds
the planet's ever seen come from that
kind of stuff
there was a I forget what movie it was
where there was a kid I think it was a
sci-fi film and the kid was autistic in
the uh the gist of the show was uh
autistic huh the new Predator movie that
was awful but also it had some good
subtext it had good bullet points but it
was now it was a whole foreign
that's how to ruin a movie in two
seconds
and they went oh we've got a predator
more thing like go go Power Rangers yeah
[ __ ]
ruined it but um not that it was that
great anyway
I I know what's gonna I know what
they're gonna do with the prey movies
you know as I said movies
was it Mercury Rising
there's an autistic kid who's being
hunted down
he wants to go home yeah Mercury Rising
yeah in the premise of that was uh
autism was the next advance in human
evolution
and you know bad guys were trying to
kill him and Bruce Willis was running
around trying to protect him yeah he was
a savant yeah
yeah
it's a good film oh there's all sorts
well uh just just I was thinking about
it a second ago while y'all were talking
about the original alien and all all
Sauron over here
just just to tie it all in together it
wasn't the the first guy who got the
chest burst wasn't it Ian Holm oh Bilbo
Baggins himself
he he was he was the uh the the Android
yeah okay uh the guy that died in the
thing was is a a brilliant actor he's um
here's the guy that did it was olivander
in um the Harry Potter movies uh I do
know his name
great actor he was in um he was in the
Chariots of Fire and things like that as
well
I can't remember his name John Hurt John
there we go John
Hurt yes thank you great actor brilliant
actor we did we make all the best
doctors
Snowpiercer might have some really good
that might be one of the best sci-fi
villains in a great way as well have
y'all seen snow peers through the film I
saw the movie series
it was so boring
um yeah the movie is quite good
I'll give you about a half hour to an
hour of really fun YouTube Just to be
watching Google
how Snowpiercer is the sequel to Willy
Wonka and just dive down that rabbit
hole and you will it makes so much fun
there goes my Sunday
he makes masterpieces snow piercer and
parasite come on
is a really good little sci-fi movie but
that's not so villainous and all that
it's more fun and friendly but
just to go back to the thing then are we
picking aliens are we saying aliens is
the best sci-fi
oh certainly it's best sci-fi yeah
um I'll stretch it out though Tim
Curry's did
even though good to be fair the guy that
did it for the the more modern movies
Pennywise was was terrifying yeah
[Music]
oh the one where he bites the kids the
kids got the birthmark he says I'll just
kiss that off
so that was the one that's supposed to
go oh [ __ ] oh
um the only other thing that's ever done
that to me is probably Game of Thrones
two or three times in Game of Thrones
that you when you're watching it and
then the eyes the eyes head the guy's
heads gets crushed or the woman gets
stabbed in the pregnant woman gets stuck
and they they go oh
let's watch that did
oh that happened in Midsummer a couple
times I was just like whoa oh that's
that's far yeah you want to pause it a
little bit and go
yeah that was a that was a great show I
love that yeah it's what it was one it
was genuinely that show though that I
would I'd watch it every week and every
week I would go I'm I must not watch it
I've got too far it's uh the finalists
are stupid and you're gonna watch it
yesterday yes of course I'm gonna watch
it next week but every week because it
was like it was been like bad Jamie
don't like this but
but I freaking loved it and once Julius
Caesar got um bum raped I was just I was
watching it going I shouldn't be
enjoying this it's brilliant
and the violence is horrendous and it
was just oh it was great it was like uh
words yeah
they're pissed off at each other they're
all going to have words
yeah I've never had dinner they'd never
have therapy they just have words yeah
and those words are always stabby stab
you don't have words brother yeah stop
um the actor that was Spartacus in the
first series though actually got skin
cancer and died so they replaced him but
actually the guy they replaced him with
was really good as well so when you
watch it when they randomly have a new
Spartacus that's why yeah you got skin
cancer and and you know to the
producer's credit for the very uh last
um season last episode you know they
went out of their way to credit the
first guy the first party and that was
really a class I thought most were just
like yeah in memory of whoever but they
really I mean you know they honored his
performances and his passing I thought
in a very sincere and uh respectful way
yeah that is I think I think it
genuinely affected them all wasn't it
because it like saying nobody and he
died so quickly and you know they found
out he was sick and he was literally
weeks later and he was gone so what they
did was they did a prequel series
instead of doing the second series while
they figured out what to do because it
all happened so quickly and so they did
a prequel series and I think he was
still I think he was still fighting it
so I think they were hoping he was still
he was going to survive so they did the
prequel series and then a few months
later so they they yeah
it's really good and he really did he
was really great at the park he really
captured the role
yeah the guy they replaced him with was
good as well but now the first guy was
phenomenal and that's what made the
success why the pop show was so popular
really yeah the the the first guy he
really captured everybody's Hearts I
think yeah it was um
yeah he's nice yeah it was a good show
like I say it's always went too far but
it was a good show
kind of the right thing that was not the
spiritual successor to Xena Warrior
Princess right
uh no the the chick that played Xena uh
Lucy Lawless is in it
no what's the one that Kevin Sorbo did
for a while exactly Hercules yeah okay
okay that was the successor technically
too it was a spin-off wasn't that kind
of they appeared in Xena once or twice
and then they did the series because
Zina was massively popular about them as
well that's another one I've always kind
of meant to watch
Andy Whitfield was the gentleman that
died of cancer Andy Whitfield yeah
honestly watch it it's great and then
obviously you'll come back when you do
watching and go oh that went too far
didn't it went yep
always went too far
what the hell happened to him have you
ever read his Twitter account well we
mentioned it last week I didn't know he
was nuts but he is and this week my
favorite one was the um it was almost
like childish Brilliance and the
government prints money so why do I have
to pay taxes
and then that was when I realized I had
a problem there's that and they're going
I'm with Kev on this one God damn it
he's he's got he's right that's when I
realized I've got a problem
foreign
Milton Freeman turning over in his grave
apparently Hercules was first
okay
I do see John 259 said Marco Norris in
the expanse but
Dorothy expands and I love the things
the character does
I'm sorry that I they could have hired
any other actor for that like every time
he was on screen I was just rolling my
eyes so it that wasn't just me I thought
he was brilliantly written in the books
but
I couldn't stand the actor on screen and
and it's not because he was trying to be
to to much uh of what I can't what term
am I not thinking of what is sure space
space people in the expanse called
people that are born and live oh the the
belters belters there we go oh my God
but
oh yeah that guy I mean I have to remind
me who we're talking about because he no
he was not uh he was uh written
brilliantly
David I can't remember right now either
they were
belter's done right I think and Marco
and ours could have been that and then
just they lost that through the
performance I thought that was part of
the expanse I was not very happy when he
came
[Music]
okay guys right we are pushing an hour
and a half
as always so
um
we'll call it my stomach is growling
and uh and I've already I've that's what
I I've tobbled after a week every damn
week I need to get a bottle or something
on another video another Channel I had
we used to do lives for two hours every
week
and I don't know I survived
it
it's like but anyway so we have picked
the most iconic sci-fi villains we got
him
um uh it was Anubis but
that was mine it was the two eye picture
um
forgotten my memory tonight is Shadows
and remember
yeah Babylon 5-1 hands down regardless
if you chose yeah yeah and I think
that's rightfully so as well and and and
my choice of the aliens but I only
actually picked the aliens because the
TV series is coming up and I thought
it'd be an opportunity to mention that
so um
no wrong that showrunner is amazing yeah
I think that's going to be pretty cool
so
I am going live again a little bit later
um with Matt to talk about and Stargate
a little bit so please hopefully anybody
wants to know will come and join us
we're going to do that about eight
o'clock
so hopefully we'll and British time so
love that to come join us and uh next
week we will be talking about some other
nonsense
normal time normal Channel
um have you noticed that no one is
complaining about how bad power rings of
power is these days I haven't seen so
phenomenally
good no one's bitching about it it works
one of the guys on podcast hates it
I love it but it's it's not perfect by
any means it's definitely coming back
but it is still by no means perfect I
think a hub it wasn't perfect but I'm
still wondering whose number is
everybody thinks that it's Gandalf and
I'll have I don't know yet
well that's an interesting
all right
I'm still thinking it could be one of
the blue Wizards
which I think did come out in the first
air or the the the the the uh
the secondary the blue wizard but
found off interesting twist so I I if
it's not Gandalf with all the nature
stuff they're talking about and bringing
in how he kind of helped regrow all that
kind of killed patch of land
could he not be radagast
could be writing ass
fun little
wizard from Hop
right you know the one with you know he
used to play Doctor Who
had little birds in his hat
had a sleigh with rabbits
I think Sylvester McCoy was the one the
doctor with the rabbit
um I I said to be honest I um after
watching The Hobbit movies I've deleted
them from my brain
so I I went and had surgery I just
removed them because they were that bad
to be fair I've still not watched The
Hobbit movies online anyway I got
halfway through the first one some
dwarfs started singing for what felt
like four years and I just care really
carefully with the plates because that's
why Bilbo baggage
oh okay uh yeah
um but but yeah I gave up and I've been
told I need to go back because
apparently the Five Armies is brilliant
but yes especially the angry flying bear
is excellent you can't argue with angry
flying best they don't like it
now on extended edition
but the extended edition does make it
significantly better yeah
it's that context is there even more
dwarf singing though or do we have a bit
less dwarf singing
far over here
far list uh the uh
the the only really cast song is uh
Bilbo's lament kind of when the dwarves
wreck his house
to have dinner
so carefully carefully with the plates
because that's what Bilbo but I can read
the whole thing I got it right here I
can I can get the books
all the books in stormy
right guys we're going to say good
evening and good night or good morning
good morning wherever you may be
so guys thank you again so much for
joining us we've had we've had laughs
and giggles and we've learned stuff and
we've mocked Harris a little bit because
he's young and pretty and we don't like
that about him at least he doesn't have
a small head this week
yeah Danny DeVito's beards growing out
lovely
um wait a minute let me get my Danny
DeVito thing
Gandolf DeVito from now on
hey
[Laughter]
I like I like Danny Gandalf just as much
as Gandolf Davido I think yeah
we're really gonna do Gandalf DeVito
upright let me get my shoulders
laughs
I need to be they've got a catchphrase
I'm not sure you did what is this get
straight from Taxi you must have had one
okay
guys
good night see y'all good night see you
guys
uh I've forgotten over the outro bit is
again I do this every damn week every
damn week you do
[Music]